but it also reflects obstacles in the
labor and financial markets
and so the black white wealth gap in
particular uh can be attributed to a
history of discriminatory policies such
as redlining
and importantly this legacy continues to
replicate itself generation to
generation
as those without accumulated wealth
cannot pass it on to their children
the second part of why i believe it's
important is that these differences are
consequential
so wealthism is protective and is
important for well-being
so increased wealth has been associated
with better health outcomes
and better financial resilience and
during this pandemic
what we've seen is that those with
greater wealth had more resources to
fall upon when the economy slowed
so it provides a kind of self-insurance
against economic adversity
it also provides access to housing and
safe neighborhoods with good schools
which confers additional advantages on
those who can afford such opportunities
and so closing the wealth gap is not
about trying to literally take away but
is trying to ensure that
everybody can participate in this
economy yeah well that's powerfully
important
thank you and you know one big
contributor to the wealth gap
is student loan debt black and
latinx students borrow more money to go
to college and they have a harder time
paying it off
if the president cancelled up to fifty
thousand dollars in student loan debt as
leader schumer and i have called for
it would close the racial wealth gap
among people with student loan debt
by about 25 points
canceling 50 000 in federal student loan
debt is the single biggest thing the
administration could do
on its own to narrow the racial wealth
gap
so i hope we'll get a chance to work
together to make this happen
i want to turn to another piece of the
racial wealth gap
and that is home ownership owning a home
is the number one way that middle class
families build wealth
but here's the ugly truth the racial
homeownership gap
is now wider than it was when congress
outlawed housing discrimination back in
the mid 1960s
and this difference can be traced
directly to decades
of racist federal policies including
redlining that denied black families
the same path to home ownership that was
available to white families
since the government created this
problem it seems only right
that the government should help fix it
so congresswoman fudge
you've spent your career working to
improve the lives of people
in communities of color if the federal
government
provided help with down payment for
families living
in formerly red line neighborhoods would
that make the difference
in narrowing the racial homeownership
gap
and the racial wealth gap thank you very
much senator it would make a huge
difference
because that is the biggest impediment
to home ownership
for communities of color is the down
payment
we meet all of the other qualifications
and so it's like us being in a race
with people who've already had a head
start because we don't have
a mother or father to give us a down
payment we don't have
the wherewithal the same kind of income
the same kind of
access and so it is like we are starting
out of the blocks
with somebody who was out ahead ahead of
us by a hundred yards
down payment assistance is a major
major uh impediment and if we can fix
that
you would see a tremendous growth
because no matter what they say
homeownership amongst blacks right now
is the same as it was in 1968
yep so thank you congresswoman you're
very powerful on this
we need to take action before the
pandemic
widens the homeownership gap even more
you know it's time for an all hands on
deck approach to tackling the
shameful racial disparities in our
economy
providing down payment assistance is one
powerful way to do that
administratively canceling billions of
dollars of student loan debt
is another i know you both care deeply
about these issues and i'm looking
forward to working with you
in your new roles thank you thank you
senator warren
thank you mr chairman thank you ranking
member um thank you to our nominees
i want to start with uh congresswoman
fudge we had a great conversation the
other day
and i wanted to follow up on something i
feel very passionately about a straight
line can be drawn
from the racist local state and federal
segregation policies of the past
to our zoning codes today and so in
addition to recommending
uh recommitting to fair housing
enforcement what should hud do to
encourage
communities to abandon exclusionary
zoning
and implement policies that build
accessible equitable and affordable
housing
well i think thank you senator and i did
very much enjoy a conversation we have
to get rid of this notion of not in my
backyard
we're going to have to find ways for two
reasons
one is housing has increased
by 10 or more a year and
the average person that we're talking
about that hud serves
are people who are not their incomes are
not rising at that level
so we're going to have to to find some
incentives
for home builders especially those that
build multi-family housing
to assist us in these communities to
change the zoning laws i mean
some of these are very very um
discriminatory and i think there are
some legal options but i also think
we need to convince them that it is to
their advantage
economically it is to their advantage
to make sure that their communities know
that it is important to them to get
people off the street
and to house people properly in safe
affordable
neighborhoods zoning is a tough issue
being a mayor i understand it
but it is an educational issue and we
need to make sure that we educate them
on
what they are doing to their communities
well thank you for that and i'm looking
forward to working with you on this and
i'll just
add that part of this is the politics of
of
of cities and towns and people who
otherwise consider themselves
rather progressive get rather regressive
and don't are not reminded by people
such as you
and and and many of the people uh on the
banking committee and in the congress
that uh the exclusionary zoning
restrictive covenants
all of that is the great grandson of jim
crow
um yeah and and we need to remember that
legacy
um even as all these progressives were
were fighting for progressive causes
except for housing next to their
block and that's something that we have
to wrap our minds around not just from a
policy perspective but from a community
and communications perspective and i'm
hoping
uh that we can work together on that
said if i'm confirmed i will be talking
with you about it all the time senator
great um last congress i introduced a
cdbg dr
reform bill that would permanently
authorize the program and get funding to
communities faster
to help communities develop housing
focused community resilience plans
do you support the permanent
authorization of cdbg
dr yes very very much and i will be
happy if confirmed to work with you on
it that's the only way we can get it out
without jumping through a million hoops
thank you very much and uh hawaii has
one of the worst uh housing shortages uh
in the united states we have uh san
francisco new york prices
and midwestern salaries uh and so um
uh do i have your commitment to work uh
generally speaking
on the housing shortage in hawaii and
specifically
on the native hawaiian housing uh
challenge in the native hawaiian housing
block grant
very much i'm looking forward to working
with you
okay uh and uh dr rouse uh
uh there's a real
sort of shift in thinking around
the economics of climate action and
i'm i and i think that this thinking is
happening in academia it's certainly
happening
markets as we see and it's happening in
the congress
and i'm wondering how you see your role
into in developing the data sets
that sort of um flesh out the case
that climate action is not just not in
conflict with an economic strategy but
it is in fact
our economic strategy and i'm wondering
how you're going to develop the data
sets to
clarify that so we don't have to have
this sort of 1970s
argument about whether we're going to
protect the environment or develop the
economy
senator i can assure you that the
addressing our climate challenges front
and center of the administration's
agenda and at the cea
first and foremost we will have an
economist one of our members and
we're hiring another economist should i
be confirmed at least
that will focus on climate and
understanding the true cost of climate
in action understanding the benefits of
addressing climate and how we can do so
efficiently
are our prime our key to what i'd like
to accomplish at the cea should i be
confirmed
thank you senator schatz uh senator
cortez massdown
thank you congratulations on the
nominations
both to you congresswoman uh fudge and
dr rouse dr rouse let me start with you
and i
appreciate both of you having uh
conversations with me
but dr ross let me start with you and as
you can imagine it's surrounding the
hospitality industry and tourism
industry because nevada has been so hard
hit our resort operators support our
whole community
but as you and i discuss when people are
willing to travel during a pandemic
it has a devastating impact on our
economy both
on the businesses and the workers that
directly and indirectly
support it and and let me just throw out
some numbers here because i think this
is important for us to understand before
the pandemic the travel and
tourism industry was one of the largest
sectors
of the economy in 2019 travel generated
1.1
trillion in spending and supported 15.8
million american jobs but we know
because of the covid pandemic
it has devastated this industry and
according to oxford economics
the u.s lost 510 billion in travel
spending and 4.5
million travel jobs in 2020. so my
question to you is do you think
that the industry the hospitality the
travel leisure industry is one
area where congress and the
administration
should focus when crafting a stimulus
bill
uh senator i appreciated our
conversation and i share your concern
about the
travel and leisure industries we know
from the most recent job report that
that is an area where we're seeing our
most significant job losses and where
have been hardest hit by this pandemic
and as i have said before getting
through this pandemic
where as safely as possible where we're
helping individuals helping the
businesses
that are viable get to the other side so
that they can
that they can participate in um
in the growth is very important and i i
believe we should be targeting our
assistants
at those hardest hit areas i believe the
president shares
that priority uh i i would say that in
the
rescue plan right there is additional
aid for
businesses but i would look forward to
talking with you
and understanding what from your
perspective and your constituents
perspective would be the most effective
ways
to ensure that we get the assistance to
those businesses in those sectors that
are the most heavily impacted by the
pandemic
thank you dr us because i do for look
forward to working with you senator
kraber and i both introduce this
bipartisan build a hospitality and
commerce job recovery act
and we have ideas after working with our
industry
uh locally and nationally about what can
be done that includes tax credits
to be effective tools to incentivize
spending and help certain sectors
recover from an economic crisis so i
look forward
to talking with you on that subject
thank you
congresswoman fudge let me um let me uh
uh associate with myself with some of
the comments that senator scott
um brought forward with respect to
manufactured housing
he and i both co-chaired a bill the
housing
manufactured housing modernization act
it was passed into law
it was passed into law a year ago
and to my understanding has still not
been implemented by hud
as a result of that he and i sent a
letter to then
secretary carson it's february 4th
asking for the quick implementation
of the new law and really what it does
is it issues guidance for the inclusion
of manufactured housing in states and
local governments consolidated plans so
i would look forward to working with you
and the implementation
of that particular law but i only have
so much time
let me talk about one other area that we
all have been
addressing which is the affordable
housing crisis in nevada across the
country it is
it is so prevalent one area though is
youth homelessness
nevada is third in the nation for the
total number of unaccompanied youth
experiencing homelessness
and the highest rate of unsheltered
unaccompanied homeless youth
so and i know this is an area that is
important for you
as well what ideas do you have to work
with other agencies to reduce the
the youth homelessness and what can hud
be doing as well
thank you very much and i did enjoy a
conversation thank you
um certainly if i'm confirmed one of the
things that we need to address right
away
is youth who are aging out of the foster
care system uh as soon as they age out
they have no place to go so hud has to
start to put in place
programs to allow them to
uh to stay in public housing at least
until we can get them on their feet but
right now it is a very difficult
situation
with the numbers of young people who are
as you say unattended but the majority
of them
are foster children so we need a program
for foster youth
and it's something that i would be happy
to work with you on should i be
confirmed
i look forward to it thank you again
thank you
senator cortez masto senator smith well
thank you so much
uh chair toomey and uh chair to be brown
and um welcome to our nominees you both
bring such distinguished records and
i know a true spirit of public service
so i'm really grateful for the
conversations that i was able to have
with both of you um over the last couple
of weeks
and i very much look forward to
supporting you
you know we are in the midst of the
worst public health crisis and economic
crisis
together colliding in our country that
we have in my
knowledge ever lived through but i
really appreciate how both of you are
talking about how we need to navigate
through this crisis
but also focus on how we can expand
on the ingenuity and the innovation
and the amazing work of american workers
to be able to build our economy forward
i want to just uh dr rouse i want to
start with you i really appreciated our
conversation
and your thoughtfulness and your
reasonableness and i appreciate
especially
how you talk about following the data
not just the averages but the entire
scope of data that will help us
understand how people are doing
at the extremes of our economy as well
as how people
on the average are doing and this gets
to a question that senator warren was
raising that i think is so important it
is the
cost of inequality to our
economy and elizabeth touched on this
with regard to home ownership but i want
to ask you
about the the challenges to our economy
because of
lack of access to capital for
communities of other black and brown and
indigenous communities and especially
the role that
cdfis and native cdfis can play in
expanding access to capital
the impact that can have on inequality
and getting our economy really moving
again
uh thank you senator you're raising a
very um important issue as we
as we think about having a shared
recovery and bringing
uh ensuring that it's not just the
average that does well but everywhere
and the diversity it's not
i i want to just emphasize that
geographic diversity and what happens in
our rural areas in particular and for
our hardest hit areas is an important
part of that
mosaic and um we know that
stimulating economic activity is the
best way to generate
employment for rural areas um and
therefore economic security
and livelihood and to ensure that the
young people want to stay in those areas
not that people have to be forced to
stay where they don't want to stay
but that they have an incentive to stay
and not to flee to urban areas in order
to find a job
so if we want to bring back vibrancy to
all of the areas of the u.s we have to
ensure that our the businesses
and the smaller businesses have access
to capital so they can get started
and importantly during a downturn such
as this that they have access to capital
so they can thrive
during an economic activity and bridge
to make sure that they ensure
and they survive to the other side so i
i believe this is an important part of
our strategy
i appreciate that and when you and i met
we talked about what this could look
like
in uh indian country in the united
states and i want to
re-extend my invitation to uh have you
come to minnesota either virtually or in
person so that we can have some
conversations about what that would mean
in terms of access to capital and
economic development
um in in tribal lands um so and let me
turn
to uh representative fudge just to carry
on this theme i so appreciate
you and your uh your leadership and i
also just want to note that as a mayor i
think that mayors
know a little bit about mayors um no
problem is too big or too small for a
mayor to focus on
and also most problems when you're a
mayor are not republican or democratic
problems their problems
about whether people's lives work or not
i believe that you'll bring that same
spirit to housing and urban development
so i want to thank you
and i want to ask follow-up specifically
on a
conversation that you and i also had
about the shortage of
housing on tribal lands and would ask if
you could just comment briefly
on um nahazda which is the most
important housing program for tribal
uh and tribal con lan indian country and
and what role you see that can play in
addressing how to shortage
um in tribal communities well thank you
very very much and thank you for taking
the time to speak with me
the hazard is something that was brought
up to me by most of the native american
stakeholders that i've already spoken
there
it's something that i have guaranteed
them that i am going to look into
as quickly as possible um and as soon as
i can
uh if i'm confirmed as soon as i can get
in the office and talk to the staff and
figure out
what's going on with it i promise that
i'll get back with you as well as
i promised them that i'd get back with
them and i
intend to do just that thank you very
much and mr chair i have a question for
the record which i will submit
for representative fudge about the
importance of maintenance and safety
needs in
a public housing um this relates to the
tragedy
soda with a terrible fire and the lack
of sprinkler systems
you can get back to me on that
representative fudge thank you
thank you senator smith uh it's my
understanding that senator van hollen
may be
attempting to log on but i has not been
able to do so yet
senator brown if you had a closing
comment you wanted to make maybe you
could make that statement now and we
could give a little bit more time for
senator van hollen to join us in in case
he's able to do so
i i would thank you mr chairman and
thank you for again to um
my friend congresswoman fudge and uh dr
rouse thank you
let me let me say in response to the
questions from a number of my colleagues
it's pretty tough to take to congressman
fudge it's pretty tough to take
a lecture on political speech from
members of a party
whose leader just three weeks ago
literally
incited a violent insurrection with his
words
the real rhetoric we should be worried
about are the lies and the conspiracy
theories that do more than hurt feelings
they make they incite violence they
undermine our democracy i
i know senator toomey at least is pushed
back against the former president's
dangerous lies about our election
i appreciate his candor and his courage
i wish
others of our colleagues on this
committee and in the senate
would show the same kind of courage
thanks to congresswoman fudge thanks to
dean rouse dr rouse for your thoughtful
answers i
i'm excited to work with you this
committee made me even more excited
about pursuing the chairmanship this
this hearing today made me even more
excited about
assuming the chairmanship of this
committee i i
appreciated congresswoman fudge comments
that these are extraordinary times that
require extraordinary action uh what you
too will do in the next several years
will be the most i
would assume will be the most important
things you've ever done in your lives i
consider my job to be that in the in the
few years ahead
um your service to our country is both
admirable and absolutely crucial so
um thank thank you chair mr chairman to
me and thanks to our two witnesses
thank you senator brown let me just uh
briefly observe i i appreciate the
conversation today i'm grateful uh to
the two
witnesses for their willingness to serve
our country
i will say i think i heard bipartisan
discussion
about the fact that we are in a
different place in our economy today
than we were back in march
and today we've got people who are
certainly suffering from very terrible
circumstances
but it is a much more targeted group of
folks than the sort of universal
catastrophe we faced in march and so i
hope
that as we develop further responses it
will it will reflect that
reality so this concludes the question
and answer portion of today's hearing
prior to adjourning i do have some final
housekeeping announcements
before i do that again let me thank uh
both of our
witnesses our nominees for your
testimony and for your willingness to
serve
for senators all follow on questions for
the record must be submitted by 5 p.m
saturday january 30th
that is 5 p.m saturday january 30th
and for our witnesses i do ask you to
respond to written questions that you
receive
by noon monday february the 1st
i know that is a very tight time frame
but your prompt responses
will facilitate this committee quickly
processing
your nominations with that this hearing
is adjourned
you